[Applaudissements]
combal charlotte julien courbet salut
jouer naim balles à thala toute la fine
fleur de la télé voilà belza de latran
compte qu'ils ont pris comme mosaïque
balzers du paf exclusif et de l'autre
côté tu as benjamin atsé benjamin
castadi bernard montiel trop content ou
pas là puisque l'accent des graisses et
tous les quatre sur tf1 ah oui mais moi
j'ai jamais eue ach hamburg courbes et
une banane l'a écoutée sur le long cours
vêtu douala comme sa grande écoute des
buts et 4 vous êtes chanteur mais là
quand je vois vos gueules on n'en sort
pas indemne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
wild eyes ça va ouais c'était bien mais
ici c'est pour tout le monde a
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que j'en prends
plein la gueule savais que je vous aime
et il ferait vite et le cadeau vous
m'avez demandé
ouais non mais pas les amis ce soir
c'est de retourner leur pense quoi ton
frère
je n'ai jamais rêvé voyez quoi et renard
et et lexie date là moi c'est très
important bien que les bords et bien sûr
c'est important mais on doit bosser on
me demande n'est pas là on fait un grand
large enfin je vous expliquerai coûte je
vous dis la vérité en plus franchement
on n'est pas là demain ni dieu ni
vendredi je vous lis vous voulez faire
une mission sur la tête de ma mère et
s'est vite noué voulait pas prendre un
petit peu de vacances pour l'argent
enfin vous expliquera rapport à la masse
qu'on n'est pas l'antenne qu'on bosse
pas en bosses mais pas pour longtemps
bien sûr mais vous bossez sur déjà deux
projets un temps à venir non mais c'est
sur la fin on sait jamais et on a un
concours de blagues ce soir je me suis
mise à faire un concours de blagues
entre benjamin castaldi bernard montiel
maxime guennic elie domota
voilà je vous ai épargné sa issaoui
c'était drôle mais bien sûr on commence
tous sexes il fallait pas rater à la
télé c'est les 24 heures de télé sous la
terrasse est très très très très très
très vite regarder qu'à val jalbert
[Musique]
regarder ça c'est marrant dernières
saisons pour théo qui a fait sur france
2 tu sens catherine ceylac alors lâché
prise et disjoncte katoch elle
s'enjaillent c'était aussi chat le vrais
artistes du moment chevaux et bien on le
savait
salou et boutard loulou et boutin
[Applaudissements]
ces marchands de musique on s'amusait
web sfr et le saoût à la maca trop cher
on a fait mal et maternelle aussi et de
france 5 agathe lecaron a l'air de
l'émission elle est hyper sympathique
sauf qu'à force de croiser des jeunes
mamans et c'est ce qu'elles vont
traverser la rive même de leur mentir
merci anar vous avez une mine mais vous
êtes incroyables à olemps ici
franchement vous et à vous est étonnante
ça n'a pas duré c'est lui mais
aujourd'hui devinez qui c'est plein
petits jours de repos au soleil le
captain igloo et donc on a vu ce
qu'avait fait le mot proportion est lié
encore à l'heure qui leur est en avoir
plein le dos plein de croûte mince et
c'est vraiment ça peut avoir des grosses
de prendre le programme pas bon refait
avant de gros nous prend de bons jeux et
beaucoup courrier pour demander ce que
notre adorable kelly rester simple
malgré le succès bien oui elle vient
chaque soir en métro kelly on a des
images après un coup de pelle
il en parlait si ray quoi qui siègent
jour à coups d'offres qui dit lui dit
quoi
comme avec notre président et son
gouvernement que d'un numéro 10 dans sa
team
on les a suivis sur toutes les chaînes
en direct est suivi comme chaque année
le président a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup marcher vous me dîtes
si j'en fais trop
il a marché devant les militaires il a
marché devant d'autres militaires il a
traversé le rond point de l'étoile se
regarde à droite ou à gauche
il a checké six personnes lui avait
piqué son portefeuille aussi passé
là-bas et militaires il traverse tut
frayeur allez bon tout est en place et
d'anticiper zarma il connaît pas son
premier ministre ils marchent à 7 mètres
de lui
il a fait que marcher on a une image du
président au foyer par l'elysée miskine
il a déployé toute sa rédaction d'une
personne pour rencontrer les français
venus assister à l'événement pas de bol
mauvaise pioche
ils sont en baisse sur l'enfant le grand
bavard au monde le petit kiki que tu
portes
est ce que tu sais ce que ça veut dire 7
ce jour là le 8 mai 1945
non parce que tu retiens une image c'est
l'étude est aussi un jour le président
avec les français notamment cet ancien
combattant qui lui donne un conseil en
scred à l'oreille bien gênant
[Musique]
emmanuel macron acier livre d'or de la
cérémonie comme chaque fois c'est plus
fort que lui dans la profité pour faire
autre chose
prête à signer le livre d'or du comité
de la flamme comme l'ont fait comme chez
ses prédécesseurs notre avis cette tombe
du soldat inconnu installer si je ne
m'abuse depuis 1920 ce soldat inconnu
qui veut représenter tous les mois non
non non non non non c'est bon mais c'est
dans l'équipe
si les fouilles quelqu'un d'une femme
comment les pieds d'une femme quelques
années quand c'est bien connu les blés
de quelqu'un qui est très bien dans ses
chaussettes en atelier beyoncé bazar mon
arrivée
la personne se reconnaître
[Applaudissements]
juste tu imagines que quelques âmes et
comment il a pu enfin comme il ne sait
qu'il a des pieds monsieur est quelqu'un
du ludique et surtout marquer non
comment les pieds je vous dis moi qui me
connaît un pied c'est pas des pieds
français non mais c'est pas ce qu'on
sait que quelqu'un peut-être c'est pour
quelqu'un qui a été touché par une
maladie s'avèrent pas c'est qu'on a fait
c'est le mec qui a reconnu ses pions en
ce moment à la télé a par avance un
fumeur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'aurais pas cru je ferais pas mieux que
ces bas prévoient pour les pieds de jean
michel prend les gars eux
vous savez moi je crois pas du tout je
crois pas du tout à la voyance et à
l'astrologie sans ôter verso je suis mal
an si ces basses mais comme moi mais oui
comment je suis vierge qui se
rencontrent ont dû s'en était pas
balance toi moi je suis ballon ouais moi
je suis pas balance c'est à dire ceux
comme moi batwa virgin mobile c'est
isabelle la balance croyez moi c'est bon
tu es là non non j'ai rien n'y fait quoi
toi montiel je suis bélier voilà dans le
douaisis et non point soleil
moi je suis bel ascendant perdant 6 mrd
kwakwa torpille ont évidemment à hirak
louis dollar est l'autre qu'on les plus
sensuelles tu sois mais tu t'écoutes
amer mais ils me demandent si je vais
vraiment au point soleil de nivelles sûr
que non pas bien sûr qu'elle soit gérée
comme ça hop il devient le 15 février la
même bronzage frère alors qu'il fait
moins 4,2 hors pair il a un truc un
accord avec les ôter la corde et il a
presque le même couleur que les pieds de
ceux d'ailleurs souvent c'est un ami un
ancien collègue de tf1
mais regardez eu des voleurs se sont
emparés de thaler légal émissions ou
moyennant on appelle 67 euros la minute
tu peux parler envoyant au sujet de ses
problèmes financiers
est ce que j'aime c'est que six ans
après la ligne elle est toujours aussi
ripoux ils sont toujours pas passés
chichov ce choc bonjour comment vous
appelez-vous
pas mal team 2018 ya la voyante
annabelle de villedieu qui incarne la
précision est vraiment dans les
prédictions c'est toujours beau mettre
en place mais c'est une question de
quatre mois 4 4 4 3 4 4,5 à la noix 404
voix la quasi je vous cache pas aussi
que parfois les téléspectateurs sont un
peu approximative dans leurs réponses
aussi a déjà fait une démarche chez un
psychothérapeute
non on ne lui vaut tout est une voyante
avec ses machines en une minute elle
sait qu'elle parle un grand sportif
comme soudeur de prendre une activité
sportive bruno mais mon préféré de tous
les voyants ça reste guillaume legendre
le brésilien des prédictions el fenomeno
du tarot lui c'est simple étape toujours
à côté youtube au téléphone tu espères
tu y vas tu annonces et une année
horrible les plus âgés roux michel il
est plus âgé michel elle a les cheveux
clairs votre ami séverine voilà vous
avez un chien vous dans la forêt des
randonnées un ennemi qu il est un peu
plus âgée que vous a dit mir non il est
plus leurs frères ou du tout là qu'une
tendance équipières à des personnes
létale vous avez un enfant vous avez un
fiso qui horrifie parce que je sentais
un peu trop fort c'est le jeu
c'est pas glamour à côte c'est le rouge
ou noir gris et bon dernier il est
voyant ça c'est en train d'exploser
littéralement ont fait une saison dieu
bénisse et surtout je voulais pas alors
on pouvait lire allez j avais je trouve
l un truc qui passent sur chérie france
3 alors à ceux qui bossent en votre
gueule ici dans la parcelle trimestre on
voit ce qu'on bossait sur la saison
comptant le régulier églantine eméyé
elle anime ce jour sur le sujet promet
un combat
ça me fait peur elle anime ce jeu elle
reçoit un candidat qui fait des compètes
de danse en cavale wall ou sebha donc
tout le monde est super pour espionner
mais quand elle creuse un peu tu te
rends compte que c'est qu'elle pas photo
le gaz quand même on a participé au
championnat de france cette année on
était encore qualifiés mais est-ce que
vous étudiez que là c'est la dernière
période en est sorti commencé à rennes
où on a fait trop de vienne sur combien
on était 40 3 et 4 en quoi un nouveau
jeu de cyril féraud a pu l sosie de
gilles verdez jeunes visiblement il
cherche encore sa fatou sylla sa pole
qui va nous le dire donc il n'y a
personne qui veulent me rencontrer
tu dois vous regardez les délires chaude
ou sur leur téléphone pour faire des
origines you fête ses 67 ans aujourd'hui
yves lecoq fait ses 72 ans grand
imitateur
ah non
c'est pas yves lecoq c'est rocco
siffredi person in need autour de la
table même pas lui et tiens noël enfants
de stars rapidement sur une photo
apparemment donald trump a donné un peu
plus que son dernier mois
[Applaudissements]
ressemble à paris c'est ici est très
beau bravo vous les voulez pas on passe
un petit concours de belote j'adore
concours de blagues c'est très simple on
avait vu ça c'est des gars qui s'est
amusé à le faire avec l'équipe du psg
il savait ouais je crois sega tour en
fait on prend de l'eau dans la bouche un
et deux buts ses 2 bat pas fait rire lot
sinon on se prend de l'eau dans la tête
on s'amuse à faire avec les copains de
l'équipe
regarde un petit peu ce salon à ne pas
rire et donc pas cracher louey juillan
d'où l'intérêt de faire des blagues
nulles partent avec un petit avantage
maxime même si je veux le voir alors
c'est l'histoire d'un mec il a cinq
tomes son script lui va comme un gant
tu peut avaler en fait un homme qui
s'appelle hawaï et les bûcherons
parce que cette agence
qu'est ce qui est vert et qui font se
saoule au chemin
[Rires]
jamais j'avais une blague sur les
magasins mais elle n'a pas su pas marché
aecon pour les biscottes pour danser en
discothèque
comment pas le temps un ascenseur
amérique du sud on appuie sur le bouton
c'était sa dernière blague de jean louis
pour moi est ce que ckac d'ahnif un
p'tit pierre un canif quantifier arbitre
qu'on n'a pas le même maillot où on a la
même passion
il a à chaque fois c'est un truc groupe
j'avais vu deux fois le guide avant les
frères ont des desseins autres à leur
poser des questions aux gens pendant
qu'ils nous répondent on s'habille à peu
près comme c'est pas pixar loin de là
parce qu'il ya des gars qui arrive à
nylon en direct on dépend bien on en
direct si je fais ça c'est pas du direct
pour les doigts dans le nez chez check
ça s'est terminé
je crois que les 20 heures 16
[Rires]
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens on est on est vachement
serré en fait dans les métros après ça
dépend la ligne comprend mais moi je
pense qu'on l'a 13 et du coup bah ouais
beaucoup de beaucoup de pros proximité
avec autrui quoi et votre charge bon je
crois sincère va aller dans le sud à la
pas ce problème là elle prend pas le
métro je passe une tête
salut ça va ça va bien et toi ça va se
faire je te remercie ouais donc pareil
je prends pas ça que je suis je suis
donc je prends un peu moi le transport
parisien quoi bon on vous laisse ces
retrouvailles un peu froide mais on est
contentes sur moi je serai petit bisou à
ma fille ça y est les fans qu'est ce que
vous pensez des transports en commun
parisiens pas grand chose je les sens
très utile mais si je peux donc en
dispense et je l'en dispense et votre
char penses quoi
ma soeur mais là c'est juste ça va c'est
la soeur jumelle ouais on a on est
jumelles on a deux ans d'écart il est
juste un peu plus poilu qu'est ce que
vous pensez des transports en commun
parisiens autour de 29 ans pour être
mieux pour beaucoup trop de monde
ces pratiques disons quoi et votre frère
il en pense quoi
enfin votre frère j'en ai pas
il va accoucher dans acea 8,6 braconnage
a pas billet philo chez moi c'est par un
aussi bon bah allez à la prochaine bêta
[Musique]
nous adorons ça me comble